Notice I've changed
nothing about states.
I've said nothing about function
approximation over states.
I'm talking about abstraction over
this set of actions that you have.
>> Well, you did implicitly talk
a little bit about states when you said
that all the states in say the northeast
room end up being sort of equivalent.
>> Right, equivalent with respect to
the action that you want to take, yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Right, which is its own kind of
approximation, its own kind of a track.
All of these are different
kinds of abstraction.
>> Okay.
>> And will allow us to do scale.
So let me just add one more thing to
this before we move on to the next line.
And what I want to point out is
that this isn't just a way for
you to think about this problem or
to sort of in a compact and
efficient way explain how you would
accomplish a particular goal.
It actually has other
computational benefits.
So if we think in this sort
of southeast room here
about how value propagation works,
right.
You took a bunch of actions in here.
You got to this good space.
Then you start backing up values, right.
So I know this is worth a lot,
because one is the biggest number in
the universe without loss of generality.
Assume one is the largest number.
And then I'm going to learn
that being in this state and
taking this particular
action is also good.
I'll just draw a little dot here.
The big size thing,
that's really good, and a smaller dot,
a slightly smaller dog.
And so the value of the states
around here are nice and
big because I can easily get
from here to the goal state.
And as I move farther
away the value gets to be
a little bit less and then a little
bit less and a little bit less,
and it sort of propagates
out into the other room.
And the way that you propagate
this information is actually kind
of slow, right.
You have to get to the state and
sort of back it up a little bit.
Your horizon is such that the value
seems relatively small and
you kind of keep going.
And you have to visit this often,
very often actually,
to back up the information to
tell you sort of what the value
of the states are, what the Q
values of state-action pairs are.
And that's fine,
that's how we learn in MDPs.
But, because I have this abstract
action, I have this go to doorway,
I can actually from here, from this
particular state at the doorway,
back up information all the way to here.
Wherever it is I executed that
particular action in sort of one step.
So I learned a lot about the value
of being in this state immediately
from having taken that and got here.
So soon as information from my little
plus one box here gets me to here,
I can back that information
all the way up to where
initially executed the go to doorway x.
And similarly,
now that I've got information here,
I can back it all the way up to
the value of being in this state.
And so I can back up information
in value much more quickly
without having to back it up sort
of one little state at a time.
So there's a lot of advantages
here sort of computational and
otherwise that will hopefully
allow us to learn faster.
>> Cool, and I think that's
helping me understand why it's
temporal abstraction, right.
So state obstruction is treating a whole
bunch of states sort of equivalently.
This is actually treating a whole bunch
of time steps equivalently, right,
that can just kind of align over them.
>> All right, and
now you'll notice that it will have
the side effect of allowing us to treat
a bunch of states similarly, because
we know that one way of thinking about
similarity between states is how their
features are similar to one another.
That's what you talked about.
Another way to think about similarity
among states is to think about whether
you should take the same
action when you're in them.
And so every single state in this
room is the same in the sense that
the optimal action is the same,
go to this doorway.